So far we have been talking
about technical controls,
whether it has to do
with authentication.
Or in the context of network security,
we talked about firewalls and
[INAUDIBLE] detection and so on.
And these are used to secure systems
that we have in an organization.
What are the assets that
need to be secured?
Who do they need to be secured from?
So let's talk a little bit more
about this organizational context.
We said, there's something of
value that is under threat, so
we need to worry about securing it.
But what other reasons may be there for
us to worry about this problem?
While there may be legal and compliance
reasons, financial data and health data,
for example, HIPAA mandates how you
can share online health data or
distill health data and
things like that.
One solution that we've been talking
about is that of course there
are various kind of technical controls.
For me to use these technical controls,
I have to understand what
kind of risk that I'm facing.
What is the threat source?
What is that threat landscape for me?
Of course the technical solution or
control that I have is going to
have an associated cost.
I have to worry about what that cost is,
and, what is the benefit of actually
deploying this particular solution
that we're talking about?